[Music]
who watches Keeping Up with the
Kardashians oh really
I've never watched one episode what
channel is it on 17 exactly who keeps up
with the Jenner's no oh are they related
a family a family right yeah
yes cuz half the sisters are one last
name of the other different dad one of
the sisters has OJ Simpson for a father
and oh wait how many sisters is there I
don't know honestly I don't keep up with
either side the family shows you watch
both shows the gyms have a shop know it
up with the Kardashians and
jamming with the Jenner's wait we don't
watch it cuz we're better than them is
that why no I just don't even know a
challenge I'm Kim Kardashian hell yeah
really who's your favorite sister oh the
billionaire the young one hi Lee I'm
glad you brought up the billionaire
because it just came out forbes has
taken away her billionaire status she's
too much money and then she went less
than no for something much worse
oh yeah forged her taxes she forged dad
you forged your taxes Jesus so she's
like I pay I want to pay more taxes why
would you want to do she inflated the
the value of her company through her
taxes or whatever can we all be
billionaires by misreporting our tax
information gets you a lot of clout you
know people want to do business with you
if they think you're a billionaire why
you just [ __ ] fought to be get to be
put on that list bro he fought so hard
he was like he almost show you all my
[ __ ] I need to be on this billionaire I
just gave it to her too
they gave it to her and Konya had to
fight his ass off his
a billionaire I'm watching me weightless
yeah that kind clangs you the
billionaire but a lot of people are
skeptical about his more so now yeah you
know cuz yeah because Kanye's part in
the family cuz its technical Kardashian
did you know then people are gonna be
trillionaires I know Jeff Bezos is on
his way to becoming a trillionaire he's
projected in our lifetime different
entry who's there
and then Zuckerberg second Berg - he's
gonna be the youngest trillionaire Wow
where does this money come from from us
well there's a lot of us we breathe they
make money it's our fault think about
how much we use Amazon a lot I'm so good
that's what's so funny everyone look I
love it okay and we use Facebook a lot
right Instagram Facebook reason why
they're rich is because they provided a
service that we all [ __ ] love that's
it yeah hello I know it's like you're
protesting the rich people on Instagram
and it's like you're making them more
rich why are you becoming a trillionaire
let me order some stuff on Amazon that's
what I say to is like alright when you
go and get gas and when you get like
Walmart like stuff in Walmart and all
this stuff right and then you're shaking
your fist at rich people I'm like um
unless you live out off the grid make
your own products do you not know that
those cheap products actually make them
rich do you not know that it's amazing
that you can even pay $3 forget a gallon
of gasoline considering all the [ __ ]
that goes into making a gallon of
gasoline but you don't even know about
the way they [ __ ] pull it out of the
ground really process it I don't say
those things because you know why we're
just Overlord monopolists that our
capitalist dogs and you know but we hate
crony capitalism though so get a little
different they don't know they don't
know the difference they'll blame the
[ __ ] guy with the shoe shop on on on
the street and call him a one-percenter
he's making smart jokes over there I
just don't get it true I hate these
donut shop owning one percenters [ __ ]
them
the political and business side I'm like
all right slow down there's ready hey
don't call me a businessman pal yeah the
one person is a bunny master master I'm
sorry I'm sorry
well maybe you should invite the Jenners
into the money master they think they
can learn a little bit maybe they can
they're not happy to pay they're gonna
have to pay you have to pay man cause I
think it will happen one so basically
the Kiley reported that that the
business her her what was her line next
romantic design made about made about
three hundred sixty million dollars in
2018 but in reality they're saying
that's closer to 125 sure if she's not a
billionaire she's definitely very very
close to the billionaire and she will
probably go it's not that close but it's
a reputation hit she got 900 million ago
if you know these people the way did
they talk about their wealth they that's
not even close bro they [ __ ] can't
believe that you're that you even just
said that frankly and that's offensive
I'm sorry
you know those people I have actually
known two billionaires I'm on my phone I
met one two billion that we flew you out
to have sex with you no but it is my
wife what no no movie [ __ ] I met with
two different billionaires for two
different movies and yeah but why are
they lighter they're fun people hang
around actually surprised really yeah
with a young Armenian girls no bladed
their taxes that's good Jessica I should
ask but yeah so she sold 51% of her
company to Cote you know girls me as my
booty it is a goty no it's a beauty
company that bought a controlling stake
in her makeup business last year and
with this news Coty shares have dropped
tanked 13% today
they're like actually you're not as
prosperous as I thought yeah earnings is
everything in that world well it knows
because of the forgery that it takes
mmm-hmm yeah so now it's like now
they're investigating even more and
trying to figure out the web of lies
that the Jenner family is concocting to
inflate their their their their value
that work
they're so influential though like Pablo
whatever they're probably helped them
yeah that's how everything's worked so
far Kim Kardashian's suck a dick on
camera it turns out to be a billion
dollar [ __ ] enterprise okay I mean
what did she make off I mean what did
she made since she since that happened I
guarantee she's made a billion
guaranteed because her [ __ ] stupid
video game alone was making at one point
she's a video game really good game yeah
but he was making at one point like I'm
not even kidding a hundred million
dollars welcome every couple months
what is it is she walking around hitting
things with the but no it was like you
can be yeah you can build your own
little Empire like like her whatever and
you always start off a second day the
game starts with you [ __ ] of our be
singers as brother hey honestly though
we can talk all this [ __ ] I'm not lying
[ __ ] I want to say something so we can
talk all these facts you don't have to
suck dick that well by the way yeah
that's you could improve her - I think
she could've don't waive it dude I've
sucked a lot of dick and I'm nowhere
near the amount of money she has not
even close I try to sell or at least
good for her she sucks dick like a
billionaire which they don't hand it you
know what I mean like she like that
means she knows what she's doing
I've always said this I breathe I think
she's a genius I really a marketing
genius dude but that's genius yeah she
came out with her kimono thing I think
that was all Mark and when we when we
say this it's not a it's not a it's not
a sense it's not a it's not a point of
morality it's like there is a skill in
order to get into the minds of human
beings and so that is where the genius
is what truck does the morality part no
no but when you praise people's talents
like that they think that you support
that kind of
so there's a separation between behind
the curtain talk right so for us we
understand the business side and we
understand these things and so I mean
outright say like Trump uses very
interesting tactics where he can do
something very little but he gets a lot
of air time and that's a genius in
itself right but then people will say oh
you're you you're you're you're praising
Trump here it's not a question of right
or wrong for me I see the skill in what
they're doing it doesn't happen on
accident that's all right but people
don't see the manipulation that's
happening right and because if you're on
the receiving end of it and you're
giving your emotions to it you lose to
the game but no one wants to accept that
fact it's like they're losing to the
game they're they're getting frustrated
they're getting manipulated and they
don't know that's happening so they're
outraged and then they're directing that
anger towards everybody and I'm like
dude you're getting sucked into the game
and you don't even know like if you're
out here gossiping about Kim Kardashian
and how much you hate her and how much
you hate her family keep every single
day she's won right but she won it is
yeah that's possible though so us
covering this entire story it's just to
change to teach it yes we're giving her
mad money right now hopefully you're
gonna get to the billionaire status and
other Jenner news the other sister what
Julie why the [ __ ] Kendall Kendall
Jenner the mom has to pay ninety
thousand dollars in settlement which is
chump change I think for big sport baby
lotion balls job change but it she has
to pay this money for her involvement in
promoting the fire festival and dick to
try to save it is she why does she get
in trouble though so did she get played
she got played but now she's getting
played more by the government because
she paid she was she was paid to a
$5,000 to endorse the festival and to
promote
and the basic talked it up to be like
this amazing thing right we all know
where the fire festival was which was
the failed attempt at making something
like the Coachella Java rolls career I'd
like to view these things of 2018 ja
Rule just cannot come back oh my god ja
Rule but yeah so the main thing that she
did that was like I guess the the it was
the misinformation that the
intentionally misinforming people that
Kanye West was gonna be performing
that's it I'm not doing it explicitly
said that in her post and whatnot and
promoted it and was trying and she said
the good the g.od music family is gonna
be there and all these things and she
it's what that employee I guess that's
what they're implying is that there was
no deal in place for a client to even
show up but she just kind of blurted it
out there she she pocketed the 275
thousand so now they're like you know
and then there's so many investors
involved for this thing right and so
they're saying like this was just a way
to rip off investors that believed in
this thing really Shady
and so every all this libraries that
endorsed it and particularly Jenner now
she's kind of like the most most
high-profile one I guess and the richest
one maybe why didn't they warn him to
tell Carney it was a trump rally he
would have gone he would have showed up
you bet you've been throwing megawhatts
yeah I'm kind of thing what you're doing
there surely true Kanye yeah Kanye is
not attracted with money anymore he's
attracted with me
yeah it's religion yep Colts Colts yeah
the code of Kanye
[Music]